How do you handle the vertigo from with the rolls naturally?
So vertigo is an issue with your temporal nerve or your cerebellum that is back part of the
braid back here. Temporal nerve is in your ear here and in your deep part of the temporal
lobe of the brain or it's part of the vestibular system. So there's multiple different causes
for vertigo. Vertigo from withdrawals, now quite honestly I've never dealt with vertigo from
withdrawal so you'd have to find out going to if you're going to really dig to the bottom of that
help with that going to somebody who does functional neurology. So there's a whole
class of care that people that are what are called functional neurologists, not a regular medical
neurologist. So functional neurologist is looking for causes different neurological disorders.
So there's different tests that can be done through in a good functional neurology clinic
to get to a root cause of different types of vertigo. And then different specific exercises
to that can help a person with that whatever type of vertigo that is. So that's the way I would
approach that. If he has it to say I'll just take this supplement or it's just not that easy.
You have to decrease the inflammation of the braid is really what the thing is. But and you've
got to find out where that inflammation is. So going to somebody who would be listed as a functional
neurologist, specifically somebody who's gone through Karek. That's C-A-R-R-I-C-K education. I've
done a lot of that. But we don't see people in the office anymore. It'll practice functional neurology
in the office anymore. This is really an office exam that needs to be done a functional neurological exam.
And so Karek functional neurologist is what you want to look up. I apologize I can't give you
quick answer for that cause it's not a quick answer.
Any time when you're dealing with inflammation that is neurological inflammation
from what a semi-quick answer, decreasing inflammation is the key. So with any even a person who's
going to a functional neurologist, they do its specific neurological exercises to help with that
function of that nerve using anti-inflammatories, which are fitted to the bioflavidoid category. Those
are things like tuberic EG-C-G-Resveratrol, Boswellia, Corsatin, Roseberry. There's a lot of nutrients
that fitted that flavidoid category. That have been shown time and time to get a different studies
to decrease inflammation of the brain. Really that's really the only thing that really decreases
inflammation in the brain. I would, you know, at least from a functional metabolic standpoint,
I would consider those types of things. But getting a good functional neurological examination
like we have to work it.